hey everybody i'm dave rubin this is the
reuben report direct message today is
november 22nd
2021 we are live streaming as always on
rumble on youtube and on blaze tv and
obviously the news today is not good
there's not a lot of
good news to share today i'm going to
try to lighten it up a bit in the second
half of the show but there really is
just like an unimaginable tragedy coming
out of waukesha wisconsin right now from
the christmas parade yesterday i'm sure
you guys have all seen the the horrific
video we are gonna
show you 30 seconds of it obviously if
you want to look away or you just don't
want to see it i've watched it twice
it's it's really really awful
but i felt we talked about it this
morning like these are things that we
have to cover right like you can't just
cover good news and usually there isn't
a lot of good news that's not really the
way the news works um but you know when
you see just sort of direct tragedies
like this tragedy is not even the right
word when you see direct
malicious evil i suppose is the right
phrase um you don't want to look at it
you don't want to really talk about it
but i think it is important we talk
about it and i think it's also important
that we talk about how the media
probably won't cover this in a certain
way while if the races had been
different and everything else they
probably would have done something very
different so we are going to cover that
and then andy noe who you guys all know
my friend he's been on the show many
times uh an actual journalist out in the
field who has been covering antifa for
years he had a really spectacular
twitter thread with some information
about the guy driving the car and uh it
ain't pretty it ain't pretty at all so
we'll get into some of that stuff then
the second story and this is where we
can start uh you know loosening it up a
little bit you know i told you guys last
week that going forward the way i'm
going to cover the covert stories is i'm
really going to highlight the positive
stuff and by positive stuff i mean when
people stand up and push back when
individual companies
and when governmental authorities when
anyone does anything to say no more of
this nonsense i will not participate in
the lie that is the type of thing that i
am going to be talking about and
promoting because i want to show you
guys we want to map out hey you got a
chance to fight the machine so there are
thousands and thousands of people now
all over the world but we're going to
show you some video out of australia
people pushing back against lockdowns
and mandates then we're going to show
you winsome sears who you should know
winsome sears is the incoming lieutenant
governor of virginia under
glenn younkin
she was on cnn and she was directly
asked by journalist dana bash if she is
vaccinated and she had a spectacular
answer and then i am going to show you
two videos of fouchy because today's
monday and they do all their propaganda
on the mainstream networks on sunday so
we're going to show you two quick ones
of fauchi just with more nonsense and if
you're listening to fauci at this point
see a doctor not dr fauci see a
psychological professional uh and then
finally we got some great stuff out of
florida with ron desantis so anyway it's
gonna be a bit of a of a heavier show
than usual it's kind of funny because i
really had a great weekend i try not to
pay attention to the news on the weekend
and i don't do social media i hang out
on on locals and i talk to people about
what they're cooking and what music
they're listening to and that kind of
stuff so i didn't even see
what happened uh in wisconsin
i saw something very quickly last night
i accidentally opened my phone for a
second but then i really didn't see it
till this morning but my my
mother-in-law and her boyfriend got here
and we've got family coming this whole
week for thanksgiving this is the one
holiday we host so i just had a really
nice weekend and we ate some great food
and had a lot of laughs and uh we
watched uh waiting for guffman last
night like it was just a really nice
weekend um and then i was like ah now
we're back in it and we gotta we gotta
cover some stuff so that's how it is but
i will make it as digestible for you as
possible because that's what i do here
over at the ruben report direct message
hosted by the rather dapper dave rubin
but before we get to any of that guys
you know we've been telling you about
shamany and jen yourself for quite some
time at the plant stem cell therapy that
they do over there when i look back at
my first prageru video while i left the
left i can see big bags under my eyes
but no more just use genus cell by
chamonix all over your face and under
your eyes fine lines forehead wrinkles
dark spots bags puffiness under your
eyes gone right before your eyes and
best of all guaranteed results in as
little as 12 hours or you'll get your
money back it's that simple now get this
genusell has now sold over a million
products yeah a million lots of
companies have tried to duplicate them
and they all fail it's for both men and
women even my assistant helen loves
their crystallus microdermabrasion
treatment and she tells me it makes her
skin feel unbelievably clean and smooth
and i was just saying to her on zoom she
looks very bright bright in the face
all across the country once people try
genusell products they fall in love and
buy them again and again from now until
thanksgiving you can see the difference
yourself with sixty percent off jan you
sell packages sixty percent just go to
lovegenyasel.com
dave that's love
g e n u c e l dot com slash dave to get
sixty percent off packages order now and
express shipping express shipping is
free that's lovegenyasel.com dave and
now back to me
all right so let's talk about what
happened in wisconsin over the weekend
it's quite horrific so let's just set it
up i'm going to show you 30 seconds of
video this was from a couple of
different angles of the car actually
crashing into and really that's not the
right way to say it plowing through
innocent people who were partaking in a
christmas parade so you got 30 seconds
here if you don't want to watch it i
fully get it but here we go
[Music]
get murdered
[Music]
god it's really unimaginable i'm sorry
that we showed it i just felt that if we
were gonna do the story i gotta do it in
a complete way and there it is believe
me there are far more graphic videos you
know just at the beginning of that video
where you see that little girl in the
pink hat she's just jumping up and down
having a good time i mean this was a
christmas parade these were people
from probably every walk of life who
woke up that morning to take their kids
and their parents and their cousins and
their friends out to enjoy the day to
celebrate the season
uh in a time that we're living in that
is a very polarized strange time where
people aren't seeing each other as much
as they should and all of the stuff that
we all know about and it's like that's
what happened that's what happened at a
christmas parade it really there's
nothing that i can add that you're not
thinking yourself but let's talk a
little bit more about the guy who did it
and perhaps get into a little bit about
why he did it and then i'll talk about
the media reaction so andy know who you
guys all know he's the editor-in-chief
over at post-millennial now he had a
great twitter thread on this so let's
take a look i'll try to read it in order
here the man in custody over the mass
casualty casualty incident in waukesha
wisconsin christmas parade has posts on
his social media in support of black
lives matter causes
george floyd and black nationalism he
also has a post about how to get away
with running people over in the street
daryl edward brooks the man who was
taken into custody uh by police over the
waukesha christmas parade mass casualty
event had posted a quote in 2016 on a
now deactivated facebook account quote
run them over
keep traffic flowing and don't slow down
for any of these idiots end quote he is
a rapper who stars in a music video
where he raps in front of a red vehicle
that looks like the same one that ran
over dozens of people yesterday so we're
going to show you eight seconds of this
and as you'll see it appears that the
very car he used in this uh terrorist
attack i will call it a terrorist attack
um it seems that it's the same car now i
swipe the vinci got him looking at me
different i can't miss him yet they are
with a stench and yeah venom when i kiss
him yeah kidnap you and mrs yeah
i don't like rap
it's just me okay uh the the twitter
thread continues to go on he expressed
hatred of former president donald trump
in one of his rap tracks he also
expressed black nationalist
anti-semitic views you can see some of
the images right there
he goes on he is a registered sex
offender in nevada he was convicted over
having sex with a child in one of his
now deleted videos he defended his
actions saying he was pimping the ho
and as you can see there's an image of
his sex offender status
and it completes here he was released
from jail just three days ago after
paying a small bail over
multiple open felony and misdemeanor
charges brooks has a long violent
criminal history spanning multiple
states and then you're seeing some of
his uh criminal history
right there okay so
where do we go with this well look
you know one thing when i ended the show
on friday it was uh right after the the
kyle rittenhouse verdict and i said that
i was going to try not to add fuel to
the fire and i actually spent basically
the rest of the day off twitter it was
like everyone was trying to own
everybody and destroy everybody and
everything else
well now we had a weekend and here we
are on monday and we have a
another incident that you know is going
to have all of this racial stuff around
it right because everything that happens
in america unfortunately is now thrown
to us or shown to us through a racial
prism i just want to go on the record i
fully believe this i've said it many
times before i think america is the
least racist country in the history of
the world we have brought more people
here from more walks of life to enjoy
and
to enjoy
whatever it is they want to enjoy to
prosper however it is they want to
prosper
that is the melting pot that is the
dream of america the imperfect but
pretty damn good dream it's why nobody
leaves but now everything is brought to
us from a racial end so in the kyle
rittenhouse case putting aside virtually
all of the details it was three white
people who were shot and were being told
that he's a white supremacist kyle
rittenhouse he himself is white he shot
three white people we're being told this
is a white supremacist event well now as
you can see by the pictures that we just
showed you and some of the information
that andy shared it's like well how is
this thing going to be framed this does
not fit the narrative that the media
likes so right now i suspect if you turn
on cnn fox news or msnbc
maybe fox news is covering this right
now but the other the other ones i i
assure you are not um because they're
trying to figure out how they can fit
this within their narrative now let's
just pause for a second think about it
the other way if this guy had been a
white guy
with a red hat
and he had plowed through all of these
people
we would be being told that america is
the most evil place ever that donald
trump should be impeached again that
there are nazis everywhere this is proof
of systemic racism all of the stuff but
now this doesn't fit the narrative right
this guy is not only a criminal but a
sex offender he has some fairly noxious
views which by the way you're allowed to
have noxious views uh you know he he
clearly is not a good guy probably
unstable mentally who knows
but this doesn't fit the media that that
a black man
happened to now plow into i actually
don't know the makeup of the people i'm
going to guess mostly white people i
don't know and again i hate this type of
story because i don't want to racialize
any everything but what i tried to talk
to you guys about with the kyle
rittenhouse thing is i didn't want to
get into the minutia every little day
this happened in the trial and this
happened and that happened it's crazy
for us to be following all of those
things we have jobs we have families
we're all trying to live our lives but
we have to know the basics of the
stories that are the zeitgeist of what's
going on in the country right and and
across the world so in a case like this
it's like if you just watch mainstream
media this story is going to go away
pretty damn quickly
but if you flipped it they'd be telling
you this was proof of how evil this
whole thing is and we have to burn the
whole system down so i think the
challenge i suppose
is you know well first off there there
are several people dead i don't i don't
even know that we do we have a number on
how many people are dead and injured at
this point we'll try to get a number i
don't know how many people are dead or
injured at this point but first off
we have to pause and just think about
that really like you know all of this
stuff happens in front of us and it
feels like a movie as if none of this is
real these are real
people who went to a christmas parade
they are dead so at least five people
are dead uh at the moment and i'm
guessing probably a couple dozen injured
we'll see if we can find that out
so putting aside the the specifics of
the of the people which i it's like
that's really what the story is about
it's like we have to make sure that a
story like this that goes against the
narrative right
this is not what the media wants to show
you this is not the sunday news shows
don't want to bring on guests to talk
about the fact that a black man did this
right
that's not racist to say they like
things that fit their narrative they
don't like things that don't so they'll
mostly ignore this it appears that 48
more people were injured including two
children so that's five dead 48 injured
two children
what we have to do i suppose and what
you have to do in your life
is to not let this story just disappear
right like we can't just let cnn not
cover a story
or just sweep it under the rug because
it doesn't fit their narrative in no way
would i blame anyone other than the guy
who did this i certainly wouldn't blame
all black people i you know at some
point i think we do have to discuss the
danger
of incitement that so many people on the
left are doing if you run around saying
that everyone are nazis and everyone are
white supremacists and these people are
evil based on the color of their skin
that's the neo-racism of the left well
then people might start doing really
awful things
but that's a very slippery slope right
that's a very slippery slope once you
start saying oh if you talk about
certain things it could make people do
violent things so like we have to be
very very careful when we're talking
about these things right like there are
people people say things this was this
is the messy stuff around free speech
now that's of course different than a
direct
call for violence but on msnbc they
spend 24 hours a day inciting racial
hatred against white people so at some
point it might
get into someone's mind that maybe they
should do something because they don't
live in reality they live in this
hyper-racialized network created
a racist reality
that's a problem so we have to think
about all of that stuff
but i i think at the moment
and again i want to focus more on the
victims because this just happened but
at the moment
we have to make sure this story doesn't
just go away
we we have to because if it was the
other way it wouldn't be going away and
now would that of course we would anyone
watching this you would agree that would
be unjust i wouldn't if it was a white
guy that plowed into all these people
and whatever his criminal record was and
the noxious views that i talked about i
wouldn't blame all white people or
anything else but the fact that the
media does this asymmetry with
absolutely everything i mean what has
there been more of a theme of any of the
things that i've talked about on this
show since i've been doing the direct
message for a year and a half the
asymmetry between what we see and what
the media shows us and how certain
things they put more weight on in
certain things they take that weight off
right so we have this constant instead
of an even way of looking at the world
where we can all honestly assess what's
going on where we can have the the blind
lady right dealing with justice right
outside every courtroom
instead we have this insane insane thing
fueled by the media so anyway so
obviously we're going to find out more
about this but i would say the media
part in many ways is more important
because now this is we're going to just
move forward and are we are we going to
just be okay you're allowed to plow into
people and kill people depending on the
color of your skin but if you're the
other color then you're not allowed to
do it and that proves a certain theory
but if you do it with this color skin
will kind of give you the out and
soft bigotry of low expectations and you
know blah blah blah blah so
it's messy i don't know that i can add
more to that at the moment but michael
maybe we can get a couple comments from
the reuben report community on that week
that i can read at the end if you guys
have any other thoughts uh which by the
way if you want to chat during the show
with other audience members
reubenreport.locals.com
all right let's move over to some covid
stuff and as i said i am really going to
try not to do just the endless onslaught
of negative covid news it's never going
away the people that want it to be here
the people that want to control you that
want to keep you masked forever that
want to keep you locked down and afraid
and you know scared of your own shadow
and all those things they're never going
away so i don't want to talk about those
people anymore as a matter of fact i did
leave my house this weekend it was very
exciting on saturday because my
mother-in-law and her boyfriend were
coming
we were going out to get some of the
thanksgiving food and i said to david he
was going to go out and shop but i said
you know what i'm going to go to the
store i never leave the house i'm going
to go to the store and see what happens
i did get yelled at twice for not
wearing my mask i was going up the
escalator you know the supermarket was
going up the escalator and the woman was
staring down the escalator i couldn't
even get to the main level
yelled at me for not wearing my mask
then later i was getting yogurt really
digging this chobani fat-free yogurt
right now some pomegranates in there a
little bit of granola and i my mask was
down again and the uh security guard
came up to me he mumbled something i
couldn't hear him because he was wearing
a mask and then he kind of went like
this like you know like i don't know
what i'm doing i'm just doing it which
by the way that's sort of what the nazis
always said you know i just following
orders don't know why i'm doing it i'm
just doing it no we have to kill a
couple people make them dig their own
ditch before we shoot them and put them
in okay no problem
anyway i want to focus on positive
coveted stories uh so first you know one
of the places where there has been just
the worst sort of draconian lockdowns in
the entire world has been in australia
it's just been absolutely insane in
australia i mean police arresting people
for walking their dogs really crazy
stuff but people are stepping up they're
fighting back they're saying enough's
enough you don't own us just because
you're the government you work for us
that's what we have to remember look at
these lockdown protests in perth
australia
absolutely extraordinary what you're
seeing there we're just doing a little
b-roll here so i'm going to talk you
through it i mean thousands and
thousands of people those are not
right-wing maniacs those are not evil
people those are people who want to live
their lives as free citizens in the
western democracy that is known as
australia they don't want to live in a
giant
island prison
known as australia they want to live in
a free australia so pretty extraordinary
now note you are not going to see that
on cnn you might see a little something
about the previous story we just touched
on in wisconsin in australia because
they can't ignore it but why is it that
mainstream media never shows us when
thousands and thousands of people and
free democracies stand up could it be
that mainstream media is actually
working for the elites and whoever it is
that wants to keep you controlled and
quiet and scared and they don't want you
to realize that you have far more power
than you think if you just speak up you
might inspire somebody else to speak up
and next thing you know three people are
speaking up and then god forbid you got
four and yada yada suddenly you're
living as a free human being the way god
intended could that be
next up winsome sears who is the
incoming lieutenant governor of virginia
she will be the second in command under
glenn younkin she was on dana bash's cnn
show and i'm not very impressed with
this dana bash and dana bash i like
saying her name like that dana bash
asked winsome sears what her vaccination
status is and her answer was quite
spectacular
saying whether you are vaccinated do you
want to say now
as i said
america if it's nothing else it's about
liberty it's about being able to live
your life free from the government
telling you what to do
and so we understand this this thing
about slippery slopes the minute that i
start telling you about my vaccine
status we're going to be down the bottom
of the mountain trying to figure out how
we got there because now you want to
know what's in my dna you're going to
want to know this that and the other in
in new york you see we have people
waiters waiters asking people their
vaccination status and by the way do you
know what else they require a photo id
to determine if this vaccine card you're
presenting is really you
who are we fooling come on
let's say you get the vaccine go ahead
and get the vaccine if that's what you
want to do get the vaccine don't force
it on anybody else we know and by the
way media they're not telling us that
people are suffering as a result of
getting the vaccine uh they have all
kinds of problems i understand it might
be the the minuscule but when you're the
one out of 30 000 that gets it it's
important to you
i mean that's just a great answer right
there by winsome sears again the
lieutenant governor of virginia this is
a woman who will now be called a white
supremacist and an evil republican and
all of those things now as far as dana
bash
it's none of dana bash's
uh it's none of her business
sorry it's none of your business data
bash whether winsome sears is vaccinated
she's completely correct this has
nothing to do with people's personal
decisions related to vaccines it has
everything to do with government
coercion do you not understand that dana
bash i understand that you dana bash and
the rest of your employees and friends
at cnn are a bunch of seals right so if
the government tells you to do things
especially if it's a government you like
in the case of joe biden then you'll
gladly do it i suspect dana bash that if
donald trump was still president and
demanding that everyone get vaccines
you'd be pushing against it because
donald trump bad guy joe biden good guy
very very simple in your simple black
and white world but her answer is
spectacular she also addresses that some
people have had adverse reactions i know
several people in my own life that have
had it and it simply is nobody's
business what you do medically to
your self so it's an absolutely
ridiculous question if you want to know
my answer to this question you might
tune in can we put the link to my famous
interview that i did
with uh gloria allred you may remember
this we posted it on the youtube channel
i was interviewed by alex michelson
who's a local fox affiliate reporter
here in los angeles i went to the
building to be interviewed they demanded
to see my papers and i said i'm not
showing you that's just irrelevant
whether i'm vaccinated or not you don't
get to know that so they made me do the
interview from home i was supposed to be
sitting in a room with civil rights
attorney legendary they always say she's
a legendary civil rights attorney gloria
alright she asked me if i was vaccinated
live on tv and i asked her when the last
time she got laid was because that's
actually the complete equivalent i have
went right that's far worse actually
because nobody wants to picture that but
let's put the link down to that video
below but that's what we need more of
and those are the people i'm interested
in spotlighting people who say no no
it's none of your business you do
whatever you want
and stay out of my life because that's
the american spirit and that's what
we're going to push anyway i'm going to
show you two fouchy videos because it's
i'm just over him just
just try to imagine anyone watching this
this is him on his you know he does his
sunday press tour with his ridiculous
softball questions and his answers that
are completely meaningless at this point
so here's just two quick ones and if you
know anyone in your life that's still
listening to this person
might i recommend a full frontal
lobotomy fouchy one we would hope and
and and this is something that we're
looking at very carefully that that dirt
shot with the mrna not only boosts you
way up but increases the durability so
that you will not necessarily need it
every six months or a year we're hoping
it pushes it out more
if it doesn't and the data show we do
need it more often
then we'll do it
oh screw you i mean really i mean that
like what else do i have to say to this
guy now six months or a year and the
boosters it's gonna boost you a little
more and i think so i guess the vaccines
don't work fauci i guess you're an
anti-vaxxer right because when people
thought they were getting vaccinated it
was because they thought it was going to
stop them from getting or transmitting
covid which neither is true when it
comes to these vaccines and finally more
from this ridiculous buffoon
i presume we have to be cautious during
thanksgiving you talked about christmas
protection with those boosters but
quickly if you will thanksgiving
well if you're a booster i mean you see
if you're if you're vaccinated and
hopefully you'll be boosted too and your
family is you can enjoy a typical
thanksgiving
meal thanksgiving holiday with your
family there's no reason not to do that
the thing we are concerned about is the
people who are not vaccinated because
what they're doing is they're the major
source
of the dynamics of the infection in the
community and the higher the level
of dynamics of infection the more
everyone is at risk but if you're
vaccinated you look at the data martha
it's absolutely clear the likelihood of
getting infected getting hospitalized or
dying if you're vaccinated versus
non-vaccinated weighs very very heavily
in the protection of people who are
vaccinated
enough with this clown again i'm only
showing you this to completely mock him
like not so that you listen to him but
you shouldn't listen to me either
actually you should listen to your own
doctor and make some choices for
yourself but he's just the dynamics of
the infection you know what i'm having
people over for thanksgiving family
members and friends i actually don't
know if they're all vaccinated i don't
care if you believe the vaccinations
work then you should not care if someone
else gets vaccinated and if you think
that this ridiculous buffoon clown two
years after two weeks to flatten the
curve deserves your attention or your
respect i don't know what to say to you
i actually i'm out of human words i feel
like joe biden being asked a basic
question i got nothing okay you see my
point just enough enough enough all
right let's move on let's talk about a
guy in public service who is doing great
work a guy who is saying i will not
participate in the lie a guy who is
saying i do not want to rule over my
citizens a guy who is saying
it is time for people to live life
freely and a guy who's also saying
enough with this mainstream media bs
the guy i'm talking about of course is
ron desantis and he was interviewed by
my fast-talking small jewish friend ben
shapiro take a look well i think it's
just a matter of just understanding kind
of what time it is now if this was a
media that was dedicated to fact factual
reporting gathering facts putting it out
then you know you may want to behave a
little bit differently but in fact i
mean they're highly partisan and not
only they highly partisan they really
are detached from reality and from facts
at this point their main goal is to
pursue their narratives and so if you
have facts that undercut their
narratives they are either going to
ignore those facts or actively try to
smother those facts and so that's just
where we're at and so these corporate
outlets um you know i think in terms of
what they've done to their reputations
with the russia collusion report i mean
they were manufacturing that whole story
they gave each other pulitzer prizes for
reporting on a false conspiracy theory
and so if you'd asked me 10 years ago
about the media i wouldn't have said
they were our friend but i'd say you
know they have a liberal bias you got to
be careful of that but but now you just
got to understand those corporate
outlets are so untethered from the truth
they are so highly partisan uh that
that's the way you have to you have to
treat them and so when they're trying to
pursue narratives uh i don't let them
get away with it uh if they're trying to
just get information to try to do a hit
piece i don't let them get away with it
and the thing is is when you have the
facts on your side it's very difficult
for them because a lot of them all they
do is recycle whatever the narrative de
juror of the day is but i would say
republicans have to understand you know
don't try to get these people to like
you okay that's not what they're going
to do
i love it i love it like what else is
there he's just telling you the truth
the media is in it for a narrative the
media is in it with democrats
republicans often fall in this uh really
bad trap of they say something
that's a little bit sort of anti-trump
or anti-republican then the media starts
liking them so then they start doing
more and more of it
that's the stuff that we need to hear
more of what we just heard right there
from ron desantis stop playing with
these people you know i don't care
anymore actually when i get now email i
get emails all the time mainstream media
things that want to interview me or
report on me and usually we just ignore
them where we send a one-line decline
back like it doesn't matter
i think at this point these things are
so corrupt these institutions are so
deeply corrupt the new york times the
washington post cnn msnbc all of this
stuff that in essence if they are
writing something you can almost
assuredly believe that the opposite is
true not in absolutely every incident
it's an incident and there is some sort
of like sliding scale there right so
like there's certain things that they're
always going to lie about things related
to race anything that they can make
democrats look good it doesn't mean that
they're going to lie to you completely
about an earthquake in indonesia right
like that one is like they can sort of
put that one on the side but when they
try to destroy someone for being racist
when they try to say that someone said
the most horrible thing you could
possibly imagine and it sounds exactly
like the type of thing we would expect
that person to say because that person's
horrible with the bad ideas you can
pretty much assume it's a lie so i think
what is happening right now which is
quite beautiful
is that as mainstream media dies and
more independent shows arise
say perhaps like this one that more and
more people will just say who cares what
cnn said cnn said something well jim
acosta is a buffoon wolf blitzer is a
robot you know don lemon's a clown like
why would i listen to these people
they're all democrat operatives and we
all know it so we need to just stop
playing ball with those things and that
would be entirely consistent with my
view of build new things right build new
things once once these guys are out of
the way and they'll never really go away
there's so much money behind it i mean
think about msnbc you know when i talk
about joy reid and these these races
that they put on msnbc every day think
about the money that is funded behind
that like msnbc nbc's in there this is a
giant
conglomerate corporate monstrosity why
is it that this giant thing who are the
network executives there that hire these
people to put them on air to tell you
that you're racist why would they do
that like we have to start on thinking
about all of these things at multiple
levels and i could hearken this back to
the first story which is as horrific as
what just happened in wisconsin is the
next step of the story is what the media
will do with it and again it is your job
to make sure that the media can't drop
it because they want to drop it and it's
your job to make sure that when they're
lying that you make sure that the people
around you know that a lie is actually a
lie
all right i've got a comment here from
vince on locals uh he said a local
children's hospital treated 18 patients
from the crash ranging in ages from 3 to
16 six children were listed in critical
condition i actually did get a text this
morning from a friend of mine
who had a friend at the uh
at the event at the christmas event and
uh she saw several people get hit where
i'm trying to find out some more
information on that and also where to
donate actually if any of you have a
really good place that we know is legit
to donate i've been asking on twitter
but sometimes it's hard to tell what's
actually legit where the money's
actually going to go please comment um
so that i can share it with other people
dragon hawk says i really did not want
to live through the fall of the roman
republic it's a little weird it does
feel like that at times but trust me i'm
also feeling hopeful right now like i am
we will build new things and again the
more they lie they lied in every way
about the written house thing they will
lie by omission about what just happened
in wisconsin but the lies aren't working
because enough of us are seeing it now
so have some faith and by the way we're
getting some wins right the yunkan thing
in virginia which then introduced us to
that woman winsome sears who i had never
heard of before this had you it's like
there are good people out there we'll
keep finding them we just got to keep
going uh guys my full interview although
it's a mini interview with rand paul is
up on youtube right now we taped that a
couple days ago we go all in on fouchy
and and some of the inflation stuff a
full interview with andrew clavin from
last week is up and we did a special
thanksgiving episode this week i did not
want to do like a political show for
thanksgiving because this is
one of the the rare weeks of the year
when you should focus uh well not one of
the rare weeks when you should you
should always focus on friends and
family and food the big three f's you
could also swap in another f in there if
you want but the big three i think
friends family and food um that's what
you should be focusing on this week so i
didn't want to do a purely political
show so melanie kirkpatrick who did a
fantastic episode of prageru uh on
thanksgiving the origins of thanksgiving
how it came to be did the pilgrims and
the native americans really just want to
kill each other was it all about
genocide or could it have been about
giving thanks and sharing land and
trying to build a better world could
have been about some of that well part
one of my interview with her is up right
now and the full of course is up at
reubenreport.locals.com
and uh i would say this was a solid show
let's give it a uh what do you think
eight eight eight and a half eight and a
half out of ten i'd say you two eight
and a half out of ten
then we shall have lunch all right have
a good day everybody